für elektronik sorgt das wollen noch
eine batterie man hey was soll denn das
ist mein bester reiter kaputt gegangen
hell freundlich willkommen zum
megaprojekt folge 250 auf meinem kanal
zusammen mit ihr was kommt da was kommt
da wer ist da haben wir mit dem
megaprojekt aufgenommen ich meine du
bist bei folge 52 und hass noch nie
hatten wir beide noch nie miteinander
aufgenommen ist relativ heftig mann mann
mann mann mann ich habe auch noch nicht
mit
hier dinge aufgenommen obwohl er ja mein
nachbar ist nachdem ihr jetzt mal eine
komplette phase jetzt also jetzt nacht
ist jetzt was jetzt gerade aufnehmen ist
er direkt nach der rettungsaktion in
anführungszeichen rettungsaktion von
simon
deswegen habe ich hier ein motto fire
und the facts fiction also ein abbau
zauberstab und ein feuerzauber
startpunkt man hat mir auch in long
beach oliver stone ist laut hier hat mir
auch lang voll boots und ein electric
jetpack wiedergegeben
allerdings fiel mir immer noch diamanten
von ihm und deswegen werde ich dann noch
mal mit simon aufnehmen das ändern die
diamanten auch zurück weil das waren das
sind eine menge level die da einfach mal
drauf gegangen sind das regt mich kann
man nicht einfach so hinnehmen musste
ich hart durchgreifen
ich hab meine frage an dich hast du
etwas rover für mich braucht nur zwei
oder drei hab ne menge aber ich würde es
toll also zwei bräuchte ich nur zwei
stück ich würde sagen ja was tausch
gegen zweier aber was willst du denn
hier keine ahnung ich dachte ich was
will ich denn jain kommt zwei management
ich brauche wirklich nur zwei rapper
common schon aber schon ein baum ist
gewachsen insofern vergiss es da eine
geschäft in ein spaß aber ein gutes
angebot hat dann sagt anja was kannst du
mir gegeben
kohle keine ahnung york kann ich dir und
bis davon geben ja gut ich gebe dir 10
aber wie viel kohle kriegt dafür samstag
ok ich gebe 20 zum 1 ich brauche ich
eine menge kleinere ich brauche auch
noch kohle also ein halbes da kann ich
rausgehen
ich geb dir 3 3 fuß weg wie meinst dass
ich warte gibt mir drei aber hier ich
stehe hinter dir auch so weit okay
handelte vor der tür
pass auf ich brauche wie viel rabatt
gibt es mehr ein
so kann ich nur ein kleines geschenk
okay die wahl kann keine rolle auf
einmal schnell die luft viel weg
jetzt habe ich die rezepte 5 gegeben 77
die messe ist der kohle wasser nein und
ich denke das reicht wirklich völlig
doch auch noch kohle du bereit ich habe
nicht viel aber drei brothers zurück
oder von hey warum so viel weil ich die
sieben gegeben habe hier hast du sie
wieder zurück kriegen kann ich nicht
fünf bekomme ich meine kommission ra the
rugged mal fünf stück ist schon wirklich
nett von dir
ok danke schön was ist dann kann ich
weiter mache ist das rathaus
was iniesta von ist das gefängnis das
schwarze dach dass das gefängnis ja da
gehst du auch noch irgendwann reinkommen
weniger im handel und bei den
schmutzigen geschäften hier lass mich
kein gutes haar an ihm auch mal böse
geschäfte wollen wir übrigens pennen
gehn erstmal und wir pennen gehn nach
ich weiß ja wohl nicht können wir gerne
machen
simon schuldt noch so helm das regt mich
schon wieder so auf dass meine ganzen
sachen einfach weg sind mitteilen
geschenkt gut okay sagt bereit wenn du
schlafen ist er wieder hatte die
eingeschenkt einfach so rainbacher aber
ist schon länger her ehrlich nicht jetzt
vor kurzem einfach jetzt ein paar wochen
sowieso er ist ja okay dann lege ich
mich auch mal ganz schnell schlafen
ach ja schöner ausblick herrlich gute
nacht
gute nacht habe ich geschrieben guten
macht genau auch noch die schwert die
spitzhacke solar seine 1
ich kann noch mal du bringst dich voll
aus dem konzept sie gerade rubine eisen
schwert so das sollte mir bitte alles
noch geben so dass in meinen platten
kann jetzt auch nicht umsetzen hier die
eigentlich vollziehen wollte und zwar
ein netter gehen und staunen
bloß hat mich unglaublich echt total
ranzig habe ich den kombis chrome weil
habe ich ein bild wie man haus aussehen
soll
also ich hab das vor gebaut im
singleplayer und dann habe ich ein foto
gemacht das habe ich dem hubraum
reingepackt mit push und jetzt kommt
erstmal an bei den aufnahmen ok wieder
mein haus aussehen so entsteht
da house okay ich brauche auf jeden fall
aus dem nat network kann ich auf
networking die netter ziegel machen
ich glaub schon jaja das dürfte klappen
brauchen etwa fans scheiße kann ich kann
ich nicht auf never reck meine ich jetzt
ich glaube das klappt aber ich kann es
mal eben testen ich habe hier was ich
probier's mal im stau habe ich das doch
nicht auch habe ich hier auch moment das
dürfte eigentlich stinknormal so klappen
in katar richtig das packen dem
kompressor ok und ja gut kommt ich bin
gerade am maschine umbauen muss ja alles
umbauen bei mir gerade ich verstehe das
nicht
ich habe ich kenne ich ja dann packe ich
bei eisenerz rein oder an den rotary
mails erhält aber ist geht er nicht an
warum praxis eisen rein eisenerz hätte
das zuweisen staub war ich kann mal eben
rüber dann kann ich das in furness
partnerin und hat ein major überhaupt
energie hat er nicht deswegen das
verstehe ich ja nicht ich schaue mal
eben vorbei aber mfs voll aufgeladen mit
600.000 eu hast du dazwischen noch so
ein level transformer ja stimmt den
brauche ich noch nicht angeschlossen
halter bei mir ist das hoch gegangen da
war mit mf weg als ob hast du die
elektra richtig weißt du ich schließt ja
gerade so meinen meine gerätschaften
einfach bahn liegt mir alles um die
ohren und mm federweg und der messe
reiter auch damit klar über
glasfaserleitungen kann ja auch gar
keine struktur zu mir hast du
rotary linkstrend hier aber nicht game
rentsch ich weiß ich brauche eine
vernünftige die die chance besser ist er
damit nicht ihn ja ok aber ich hab aber
ich bin ich auch im gleichen gebiet
eigentlich ich bin dabei mein schön mfs
anzuschließen der kann zehn millionen
energie speichern zehn millionen mann
das ist so krass
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das alles
brauchen werde wenn ich das voll hab ich
brauche auf jeden fall elektrisch
diamant meine ich oder braucht man auch
nicht okay kommt überhaupt kein plan
ich kenne ich alle rezepte nicht und ich
hab schon wieder egal dabei zum glück
noch je zwei gold- cable ein blödmann
ich habe gerade schon mehr genau das
falsche mann hätten in der spitzhacke
hier gerade ein gerät abgebaut
es ist das gerät kaputt mache so viele
geräte kaputt es gab sogar schon bei mir
aufgefallen so unnormal richtig blöd von
mir
so ich habe jetzt vier komme ja ich bin
noch da so gut weil ich doch immer nur
einen service rausgekommen redet nicht
denn ich bin gerade wirklich viel
elektronik circus jetzt noch eine
batterie hey was soll denn das ist mein
base array kaputtgegangen war terry
murray
ich wollte den abbauen wie macht
momentan make-up habe ich gemacht geht
jetzt habe ich meinen blog
na ja das ist mir aber auch schon
verlauf passiert das ist doch richtig
kümmern
die chance ist wie bei zehn prozent und
es geht immer noch mehr kaputt als die
meisten übrigen des megane elektronik
entstammt ist die chancen eine 100% dass
du mal was richtiges haus kriegs
erfreulichen kegel sind darf ich mir die
mal aus leinach die french muss komplett
fertig sein damit also die muss neu
seine mannschaft nicht noch in eine neue
branche herrsche das motorrad was ich
höre ich nicht wenn ihre aufnahme sieht
der mfs uhr an dann muss hier der mv
transformer ranocchia astrium gebaut ich
werde ich werde ihn jetzt auch noch mal
kaputt machen ich werde endlich hat
einmal geklappt
so ok
zertifiziert
wo ist man ja ich hab ein elektriker wo
ist mein mfs uwe festen weg ist ich hab
ja alles konfus abbauen ja ist das geil
ist das geil ehrlich hast du schon
hammer ja ich habe elektriker darf ich
mir die vielleicht mal ausleihen wenn
ich mal unbedingt eine braucht kann ich
gegeben hätte mir etwas zurückgekommen
ja klar wer anderen hilft der punkt auch
selber hilfe so hier möchte ich den rmv
transformer level transport als frauen
ich bin hier mit der tz alex soll rechts
im fort fun traum hat er genau dann muss
wird das geht ist ja alles in die luft
dauer alter habe stromschlag bekommen
vom mfs und guckt euch das an 410
millionen energie kann ich in diesem
schönen mfs uhr speichern ein traum und
es geht richtig schön steil hier
herrlich ski okay aber wenn ich den mlp
doch jetzt abbaut ist die komplette
energie doch weg oder ich auf jeden fall
da muss jetzt auf der höhe lassen
so jetzt aber so kompressor ja okay das
kommt der nachher alles in meinem haus
deswegen bei euch das ist jetzt noch die
höhe gebraucht dass der ganze jetzt
erstmalig gehe erstmal mir ganz kurz
nase putzen muss als ganzes meine
zuschauer auch unterhalten
ja klar ich bin hier gerade schön so
leute ihr könnt mir daumen die daumen
drücken ob das so klappen wird oder
nicht denn ich bin hier gerade gut
stimmt dem mailserver geschrottet und in
pulver reiser den kann ich nicht
verwenden
denn ihr dürft ihr raten pulver reiser
kommt aus welchem ort pack dem dom nicht
aus industrial kraft und damit ich mich
jetzt für mich nicht täusche ich dass
wir nicht mit meinem mso padding so naja
da will ich jetzt im mfg
wie baut man den schönen noch mal
das steuer glaube ich oder geht es aber
auch mal und achtete etwas maschinen
blog es geht ja wirklich noch da
teilnehmer ganz schnell aber ich hab ich
genug kupferkabel extractor genau das
teil möchte mir auch mal bauen und wie
teuer ist doch als sich jetzt wie soll
man simon ist einfach so ein spaß die
waren ganz nah teams sind weg ein
komplettes essen alles einfach man euro
ich habe ich meine spitzhacke einkommen
ohne mitleid für concord jetzt alle vom
bildschirm ich möchte nicht wissen
wieviele da gerade mitgemacht haben na
gut aber andere frage
glaub das wird die aufregung ja auf
jeden fall immer aber ich fand das so
lustig ne wir das war so geil
na gut so warten mfg.com jetzt erstmal
noch koffer cable dran dann die koffer
cablecom jetzt sachen wie ich weiß nicht
induction feldes und so ich glaube die
brauchen den lv transformer oder also
ich weiß auf jeden fall das meinetwegen
wenn man von einem nsu auf dem
mailserver energie übertragen möchte
braucht man einen gott was welcher was
das war mmv transformer und von einem m
f e bei dir brauchst du ein level
transformer also ein 11 aula wolltet nee
du brauchst einfach nur ein genau lv und
dann transform allein elf anstrich
transformer verlor wollte dann der
machtmittel medium wolltet zu low
voltage ich brauche auf jeden fall
erstmal werk kopper cable
so ist erst mal gemeinsam back ist
jedoch nicht es ist alle ohne doch nicht
der mann kann sich auch täuschen
geiler baum alter hat er bei mir erst
mal an einem stamm auf einer stange
seite je zwei reisen cool ist und das
auch was von cool wenn da jetzt tragen
kommt dann aber ich würde so lachen war
es auch bei der karl hochgehen würde
lediglich fand allerdings kann der lv
transformer ich glaube der form dass
nicht um
oder sind die ich überhaupt verbunden
doch die vereine schon
ich möchte da auch nichts falsches sagen
weil ich bin auch nicht darüber pro
darin wie man bestimmt auch im gespräch
mit mir aus rotary majors auch bei null
rpm
ich würde am liebsten gerade echt mal
ganz locker flockig einfach so in meine
single player welt gehen mir das da
anschauen wie ich das mag ja ich habe
auch eine singleplayer welt der test
dich immer vor der aufnahme solche
sachen wie hier mit mehr ist auch aber
muss einfach sein und trotzdem geht mir
so viel kaputt so egal
hast du ein ex traktor ja dafür den mal
benutzen